[Música]
[Aplausos]
las partes de mi cuerpo que son
sintéticas y que mis amigos y humanos me
hicieron el favor de palabra
pero lamento decepcionar
otro secreto y tengo un montón de 10
ritos por todo el cuerpo humano mitad
máquina y en alguna ocasión uno de mis
doctores me dijo que yo no era más que
un cadáver recalentado déjenme les
platico cómo es que eso pasó cuando yo
tenía tres meses de edad tuvimos un
accidente automovilístico bastante grave
les prometo que yo no iba manejando pero
a raíz de eso me tuvieron que instalar
un montón de fierros mangueras válvulas
y pedacitos de metal en el cerebro por
el cuello en el abdomen y en una de mis
piernas
y eso nos lleva al siguiente punto
siempre fui lo que a mí me gusta decir
una niña de hospital quiénes somos los
niños de hospital
los niños de hospital somos esos niños
que cuando salíamos de la primaria nos
íbamos a que nos hicieran análisis a que
nos sacaran sangre a que nos hicieran
estudios o nos operara yo conocía mejor
los nombres de las especialidades
médicas que los de mis personajes
favoritos en las caricaturas y tenía
bastantes más lipo verbs con mis
doctores que con mis amigas
pero no me pongan esas caras tristes que
ya los vi la verdad es que ser un niño
de hospital es algo increíble yo me la
pasé maravilloso
les voy a pedir que se acuerden cuando
ustedes eran niños cuál era su juguete
favorito o el amor o un juguete que no
tenían pero con el que soñaban tal vez
era un gadget una bicicleta un carro o
un robot no lo sé ya se acordaron
déjenme les presumo de uno de mis
favoritos este juguete tenía luces
piezas que se movían
un montón de partes increíbles a veces
la cia de máquina en el tiempo a veces
la silla de cohete espacial
y lo mejor de todo es que venía con un
asistente al que le pagaban
específicamente para que fuera parte de
mi tripulación a veces hasta me
inyectaban un líquido fosforescente que
me daba superpoderes para asegurar que
mi misión fuera todo un éxito se veía
más o menos así ya les dio envidia
bueno pues déjenme les platico más
acerca de los niños de hospital y de lo
bien que no la pasamos para que me
quiten esas caras tristes en alguna
ocasión que estaba en terapia intensiva
infantil yo ya estaba un poquito más
grande tendría unos 11 12 años pero
había un niño en una cama cercana a la
mía que tenía 17 años más o menos que
era uno de esos niños que todo el día se
están riendo y cantando y brincando y
que nada más con verlos te llena de
ganas de estar vivo y de ser feliz y de
tirarte al piso a jugar con ellos bueno
pues a nosotros en los niños de hospital
que vivimos tanto tiempo en los
hospitales como siempre estamos haciendo
desorden nos pasa muy seguido que la
manguerita por donde nos baja el suero
se nos hacen nudos y se nos llena de
mugre y cosas no entonces muy seguido no
la tienen que estar cambiando los pobres
enfermeros y cuando eso pasa
evidentemente la sangre viene a presión
nosotros los niños de hospital sabemos
eso muy bien y este niño del que les
estoy hablando que por cierto era súper
fan de spider-man se lo sabía perfecto
entonces un día que llegó el enfermero a
cambiarle el catéter él se le salió por
abajo del brazo y salió corriendo por
todo el pasillo cantando la canción de
spider-man y disparándole a todo el
mundo
no se preocupen a unos segundos más
tarde lo teclearon entre todos los
enfermeros y no pasó a más pero les
platico eso para que vean como de verdad
nos sentimos como superhéroes cuando
estamos ahí de hecho a mí me pasó algo
que me hizo sentirme como superhéroe una
vez yo tenía antes ya no lo tengo pero
tenía un tubo que me pasaba del cerebro
al abdomen y se veía no abajo de la piel
yo sabía como que lo tenía pero no
ubicaba muy bien como porque yo para que
yo estaba muy ocupada jugando y haciendo
mis cosas y no me importaba saber los
detalles pero un día se me reventó y
cuando se me reventó se me veían todos
los pedazos por abajo de la piel de una
manera impresionante
yo no me asusté pero mi mamá así se
asustó un poquito yo veía que mi mamá
estaba asustada eso me ponía nerviosa
pero pues así son los adultos no se
estresan entonces me llevaron al
hospital y me pusieron aparte en un
cuarto donde de repente entró una
enfermera y me empezó a hablar en ruso
en alemán o no sé en qué idioma decirme
palabras como válvula de deriva
del líquido encefalorraquídeo y cosas
que yo no entendí si yo me quedé como
que it's me lo repitió y le volví a
decir no tengo idea de lo que me estás
diciendo se abrió los ojos grandotes la
enfermera y me dijo no sabes no sabes
verdad y yo de qué hablas y ya hay no
sabe si se salió como a los 10 minutos
entran con la cola entre las patas mi
mamá y uno de mis neurocirujanos con
cara de regañados pues a comentarme que
se les había pasado a decirme verdad que
era mitad robot mitad humana y para
explicar me traían una o una radiografía
donde se veían todos mis perritos de la
cabeza y del abdomen y los tubos y todo
lo que tengo ahí flotando por adentro si
ellos pensaban o sea me dijeron y se
quedaron así con que pensaron que iba a
empezar a llorar oa gritar yo les rebate
al doctor la radiografía y me acuerdo de
ese momento como si fuera ayer la veo y
todas esas cosas que tengo adentro de mi
cuerpo y que me hacen funcionar y me
sentí como si acabara de llegar charles
xavier a decirme que me iba a unir a los
x-men
no saben ahí agarré mis superpoderes y
pues bueno ese fue un momento
maravilloso y no solamente soñaba con
ser parte de los x-men ahí mientras
estaba en el hospital aveces desahuciada
a veces no tanto tenía otros sueños
uno de ellos era ser actriz y lo logré
logré actuar este como ya les platicaron
para televisión azteca para telemundo
trabajé de history chanel le trabajado
en méxico en eeuu en francia en españa
ha viajado por todo el mundo y esto es
relevante porque yo les quiero explicar
cómo es que una niña que creció
desahuciada en los hospitales a cuya
familia le dijeron más de una vez que
pues se fueron despidiendo logré cumplir
todos esos sueños a lo mejor ustedes
tienen algún niño de hospital en sus
vidas a lo mejor es tu hijo tu vecino o
tu sobrino tu amigo y entonces yo les
quiero platicar como fue mi experiencia
para que ustedes pues lo tomen en cuenta
en sus vidas
o algo muy importante en mi vida que
fueron mis papás mi papá médico se
encargó de diseñar y supervisar toda la
instalación de mis refacciones y mi mamá
siempre me dijo que yo podía hacer lo
que yo quisiera hacer siempre y cuando
lo que escogiera fuera la mejor mi mamá
nunca me dijo pobrecita es que a ti te
duele es que tú estás enferma es que tú
no puedes porque se te van a salir los
tubos por las orejas no no no mi mamá me
dejó jugar mi mamá me dijo que hiciera
la tarea y que recogiera mi cuarto lo
cual pues no me gustó tanto pero qué le
hacemos y ese es el chiste porque para
mí ser así era normal yo pensaba que
todos mis compañeros salían de la
primaria y se llevan al hospital todos
tenemos algo que nos hace diferentes y
que nos hace distintos frente a los
demás pero que para nosotros es normal
no a lo mejor es tu color de cabello a
lo mejor tienes un lunar en la cara que
todo el mundo se acuerda el chico del
lunar pero tú no andas por la vida que
hoy tengo quiero alcácer oh mi lunar
tengo que ir al trabajo mi lunar ya se
me hizo tarde para la escuela mi lunar
no verdad para mí es igual o sea yo no
ando pensando que si tengo la cabeza
llena de fierro
o que si tengo 36 cicatrices o no para
mí mi vida es así y esa es mi normalidad
para todos los niños de hospital si tú
no les enseñas si tú no nos enseñas que
nos duele que somos diferentes que
estamos enfermos
nosotros vamos a crecer normales por
ejemplo cuando yo me siento mal si tengo
migraña pues sé que tengo fiebre sé que
tengo presión detrás del ojo y sé que
tengo medio dormido al cráneo pero yo
hago mis cosas voy a la escuela voy a
trabajar voy al súper porque para mí eso
es normal y si a mí de niña me hubieran
enseñado a poner todo mi enfoque en lo
que me hacía diferente en lo que me
hacía estar enferma en lo que me dolía
pues hubiera crecido pensando sólo en
eso ahora yo entiendo que cuando te
abren el cerebro y te están fierros
adentro no es el único tipo de dolor que
existe hay otros tipos de dolores que
pues todos tenemos que enfrentar todos
los días y es decisión de cada quien si
nos vamos a enfocar en lo largo afilado
brillosa y grande de la aguja que nos
van a meter en las venas
o si nos ponemos a cantar la canción de
spider-man y le disparamos telarañas a
nuestros miedos esa es nuestra decisión
otra cosa que también podemos decidir es
ayudarles a los demás a enfocarse en lo
maravilloso que es estar vivo y en todas
las cosas buenas que tenemos a nuestro
alrededor en vez de enfocarse en ese
dolor o en ese problema o en esa cosa
que te hace diferente de manera negativa
porque también podemos usar el dolor y
las cosas malas para obtener cosas
buenas en nuestra vida les voy a contar
otra historia pero por favor no se las
cuenten a mis maestros de prepa porque
se pueden enojar todavía conmigo en
alguna ocasión teníamos que aprendernos
un baile para un festival en la escuela
éramos un grupo de niñas que nos dejaban
salirnos todos los días de clase para ir
a ensayar no necesito decirles que no
enseñaba ensayábamos si no hacíamos nada
verdad entonces cuando faltaban tres
días obviamente no nos sabíamos la
coreografía y nuestra maestra muy
enojada nos hizo ir a las 7 de la mañana
en sábado
toda la tarde para ensayar entonces de
repente yo sentí que ya tenía como pues
mojada la pancita y le di vuelta hoy le
digo a mi mejor amiga oye mira ya estoy
sudando de todo lo que estamos bailando
las dos volteamos a ver mi mano nos
volteamos a ver y ahí se tomó la
decisión resulta que lo que tenía en la
mano no era sudor era un poquito de
sangre porque pues de repente mis
cicatrices se abren y hay que remendar
las entonces pues yo me senté me hice la
que me estaba muriendo y entonces nos
salimos fuimos a que me conocieran
rápido de la cruz roja' y nos fuimos a
comer helado todo el día en el moll sí
ya ven que el dolor si puede servir para
su beneficio de vez en cuando niños no
hagan eso en casa pues bueno antes de
despedirme quiero contarles una historia
que yo siempre he dicho que es lo mejor
que yo tengo para darle a otro ser
humano en una de las tantas ocasiones
que después desperté en el hospital en
pedacitos sin saber que me había pasado
abre los ojos y hay entre unos 8 y 12
doctores y enfermeros cosiéndome y remen
dándome por todos lados
yo estaba en una de esas cambios en las
que estás como medio sentado como las de
las dentistas entonces nada más veía
para arriba no podía ver para abajo solo
veía las cabecitas de la gente pasar y
dije bueno pues ya me la haces ni para
que pregunto mejor ahorita que terminen
ya que me digan qué pasó cuando se me
acerca la cara una de las doctoras se
baja el cubrebocas y se me queda viendo
con esa cara que conozco también que
hacen los doctores cuando ya valiste y
me dice sara te tengo que decir algo y
yo sí doctora qué pasa ahora imagínense
por favor que ustedes están en esta
situación y que su doctor llega y les
dice lo siguiente imagínense cómo
reaccionarían
te falta un dedo se te cayó un dedo
imagínense que como les digo pues yo
estoy viendo al texto no puedo voltear
yo no sé si es un dedo del pie no sé si
es un dedo de la mano no sé si él es el
pulgar no tengo idea
ya se imaginaron cómo reaccionarían
ustedes si les faltara un dedo
quieren saber que hice yo esta es la
cabeza para atrás soltó una carcajada
que me salió del alma y le dije ay
doctora estoy viva esto creo que me
importa un dedo
para mí ese dedo no valió lo suficiente
para quitarme la emoción que sentía en
ese momento de saber que seguía viva hoy
esta semana este mes este año que ha
valido lo suficiente para que a ti se te
quite la sonrisa y la emoción de estar
vivo
se los dejo de tarea gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]